So here's a machine that is sometimes referred to
as Pavlov named after the Russian psychologists who was
studying gastric juices and then figured out how animals
learn. So I don't know why it's called that
in this particular case but, here's what the machine
looks like. It says start off cooperating and as
long as the opponent keeps cooperating, then cooperate. So,
so far it sounds a lot like tit for tat.
>> Yeah.
>> If you defect the then move to the defect state. So,
okay still looks like tit for tat. And
again, this defect state has two arrows coming
out of it. But their reversed from what they were in tit for tat. Here it
says, if you cooperate with me, I will
continue to defect [LAUGH] against you. But if
you defect against me, then I'm willing to
cooperate with you. So, that's a little strange, right?
>> That is a little strange, yes.
>> So, you know, the way to get me to stop defecting against
you is to defect against me. And then, I I become cooperative again.
>> So, in other words, take advantage of you
until you sort of, pull a trigger on me.
>> Seems like it. Yeah.
>> It's a funny thing. So so again, so tit for tat is like repeat
what the opponent did. Pavlov is basically cooperate
as long as we're agreeing. If we both
defect, I'll cooperate. If we both cooperate, I'll
cooperate. But if we disagree, if I dis,
if I defect and you cooperate or you cooperate and I defect, then I will defect
against you on the next round. That sort of makes sense.
>> Really?
>> Yeah, right? I mean, it says: if you're cooperating, I'm going to
cooperate. If, we're both going to start out cooperating. And then if you ever
defect on me, then you have basically attacked me, and so I'm going
to defect on you. Unless you start cooperating again, in which case I think
that you're, you're being reasonable, because of what I
did, and so now we're going to start cooperating again.
>> Except that's tit for tat [LAUGH].
>> No, you're right. You're right, I, I take
it back. It doesn't make any sense, too many.
>> Yeah, it's weird. It's a little bit weird.
>> too many V's. Too many V's.
>> Too many V's?
>> Mm-hm.
>> In Pavlov.
>> Yes.
>> Two V's. Yeah, but you can think of them being like arrowheads.
>> Oh well then that makes much more sense.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, so it's this weird thing where I'm going
to continue to defect against you until you realize I'm hurting you, you punch
me once. [SOUND] And now okay, good, we're even again. We good? Yeah we're good.
>> Oh this is like men on a basketball court.
>> Yeah, sure but, now here's the question.
Is this Nash? So, we'll make that a quiz.